COMMITTEE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
SENATE ABOUT YOUR BILL PRESENT
BATES HERE IT'S PRESENT DODD
GALGIANI HERE GALGIANI PRESENT
MCGUIRE.
MORALE.
WERE ALL PRESENT ROUGH ROUGH
PRESENT RUBIO.
RUBIO PRESENT SKINNER STONE.
I'M BURKE.
NUMBER PRESENT CASKEY BUT LOOK
AT THE PRESENT MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
MCGUIRE PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AND THE FIRST ITEM IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IT'S JUST ONE
ITEM IT'S SB SIX FIFTY SIX
GRAHAM A MOTION APPROVING THE
CONSENT COUNTER.
WHERE MOTION APPROVING CONSENT
COUNTER THE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE?
THIS IS AN ABOUT SIX THIRTY SIX
BY SENATOR HUESO THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
CENTER ABOUT HI BEL I BATES.
BATES AYE DODD.
GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI AYE-MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I'M AROUND.
WELL I ROUGH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STONE.
NUMBER.
NUMBER I WOULD COUNTY.
HI BECAUSE HE AYE [inaudible]
RECENT [inaudible]
YEAH.
THIS IS THIS IS GOOD MAN HOURS
OF AREAS FOR CLOSE GONNA SKINNER.
I CAN SKINNER AYE. TWO ZERO SIX
WE HAVE TEN LOS IN FAVOR THE
MOTION IS CARRIED.
THAT PASSES THIS ME THIS IS A
JOURNEY